[音楽]
[拍手]
皆さんこんにちは
筑波大学
9年生の
井上俊です
皆さんは大学9年生という生き物を今まで
見たことがありますからおそらく
遭遇する機会はなかなかないんじゃないか
なと思います
一般的な大学生は大学を4年で卒業します
が4年生大学に9年間いると一体どんな
言葉が起こるのかその一部を今から皆さん
にご紹介したいと思います
まずこちら
筑波大学の解説科目一覧シラバスですね
僕の在学中に大学のカリキュラムが変わっ
て
僕が卒業しないせいでここに残り続けて
いる授業があります
また大学生は研究室に入ると思うんですが
僕が研究室に入った時
先輩は全員年下で
僕よりも先に
研究室の指導教員が先に大学から出てき
ました
また後輩が先に大学を出て働いていること
もあってよくご飯を奢っていただいたり
なんてこともあります
留年ってお得ですよね
皆さんこちらの
食材を購入薬という花見たことがあります
か
筑波の自然植物園にある世界最大級の花で
最短で2年に一度しか咲きませんこの花の
開花は
世界的にも珍しいのですが
僕が大学に入学してからもう4回咲きまし
た
さて
皆さんそろそろお気づきかもしれませんが
皆さんの前に立っている
本日の3番目のスピーカーは
ご覧の通り
ポンコツ大学生です
実は大学の制度上も休学や在学の機関が
残っていなくてあと半年で大学を出なくて
はなりません
卒業まであと半年
真面目に就活しようと言われそうですが
実は
就職活動全くしていません
では何をしているのかというと今世界で
初めてのある職業を作ろうとしています
それはこちら人力飛行機のプロパイロット
です
前日飛行機のパイロットというと
テレビ放送されるトリミングコンテストを
イメージされる方が多いのではない
でしょうか
その通りで
ペダルを漕いでプロペラを回し空を飛ぶ
飛行機のパイロットをしています
実は大学生活で鳥人間コンテストに3回今
まで出場しまして
現在3チームのパイロットを兼任してこれ
までに大きな人に飛行機を飛ばしました
20代半ばでこれだけの飛行経験を積むと
いうことは人力飛行機の世界でも
相当珍しくて今日本で一番機会に恵まれて
いるパイロットだと自負しています
僕がここまで人力飛行機のパイロットとし
て経験を積めた理由の一つにやはり大学に
9年間いたことというのがあります
現在は大学に9年間いて良かったと
制度が許すならあと1年でも痛いなと思っ
てるんですがそんな僕にも大学を7年で
卒業しようとしていた時期がありました
いや7年でも十分長いんですけど
結局僕はある出来事があって大学に残る
決断をしましたそれがこちら
印紙に落ちました
ところでこのトークのタイトル
皆さん覚えていますか
ありませんですいや印象落ちてるじゃんっ
て皆さんは思うかもしれませんが
僕にとってはそうではありません
卒業を1年先に延ばし早めに就活の
スタートダッシュを切ることができました
そして最も期待企業のインターンに参加し
順調に就職活動を進める僕はこうなりまし
た
採用試験に落ちました
やっぱり失敗してるなんて思うかもしれ
ませんが大丈夫です
飲酒で落ちても
就活に落ちても
飛行機落としても
僕にとっては失敗ではありません何か
やらかした時に
僕は3つの方法で
対処しています
1つ目
糧にする
よく言われるやつですね
挫折した経験を踏まえて成功するまで
頑張ればいい的なやつ
モチベーションが続きそうならこれで
頑張ります
発明王のエジソンはこんな名言を残してい
ます私は
失敗したことがない一万通りのうまくいか
ない方法を見つけただけだとこのような
失敗に対する前向きな姿勢が
多くの発明につながったのかもしれません
2つ目
失敗したからこそ出てきた道を進む
ノーベル賞を受賞した山中伸弥先生は一度
は医師になったものの自身の不器用さを
顧みて研究者を志したという逸話があり
ます
もしもあのまま一生続けていたら
IPS細胞を発見してノーベル賞を受賞
するといった功績はなかったかもしれませ
ん
僕も
印紙就活でやらかして大学9年生のルート
を選びました
しかし逆に考えてみると
僕は飲酒と就活でやらかしたからこそ大学
9年生になれて今の自分があるんです
あの時不運にも飲酒に受かってしまってい
たら
自分はここに登壇できていなかったし
プロのパイロットを目指すなんてことも
なかったかもしれません
ここまでの2つは
失敗しても諦めるなだとか
失敗は成功のもとなどの言葉として
多くの場面で口にされてきました
しかし
実行するためには挑戦し続けたり
自らの行動を変える必要がありました
そこで3つ目これは
失敗を失敗と捉えさせないだけではなく
僕を様々な挑戦に導いてくれる最強の対処
法です
[音楽]
ネタにするこれは本当におすすめですまず
カバーできる範囲がめちゃめちゃ広いです
糧にするとか
失敗したからこそできた道を進むっていう
のはやらかし質問をどこかでかっこつける
必要があるんですが
ネタにするのはもうなりふり構わずでき
ます
こちらを実践している著名な方
いらっしゃいます
霜降り明星の粗品さんです
彼は
ギャンブルに没頭するも負け続けていまし
て
障害収支マイナス2億円くんとして
YouTuberで活動し
現在多くの注目を集めています
この方法は
他にも
失敗が大きければ大きいほど
ネタとしては面白くなるためより思い切っ
たことに踏み切れるという点で
優れています
全部ネタにしてしまい精神を身に纏った僕
は何かやらかした時にこう考えるように
なりました
美味しい
失敗というのは大層なものでなくても
大丈夫です
ちょうどこのトークの健康を考えていた時
にこんな失敗があって
僕あの研いだお米を床にぶちまけたりあと
はその時に一緒に卵も床に落としてしまっ
たんですけどこの話ししようと思ってたん
ですが
皆さんもっと気になることありますよね
なんでこいつ松葉杖ついてるんだっていう
これあの
実は3日前にやらかしましてもう原稿完成
してるんでこれそのまま持ってきたんです
けど今日このお米と卵の話しません松葉杖
の話もあります
僕アルバイトでお寿司の配達してまして
筑波大学の中を
ブーンって走ってたんですよで筑波大学
ってすごく自然豊かなキャンパスで四季が
感じられるようになってるんですけど今の
季節ってすごい落ち葉がたくさん落ちてる
んですねそれで
落ち葉が落ちてて
完全に道路の段差が隠れててそれで落ち葉
があるとなんかそこに突っ込んでみたく
なっちゃうじゃないですか
骨折です
じゃあここから
元々用意してた健康に戻りますね
皆さんもネタにした経験ないですか
成果を出すことも大事ですがそこに
ばっかりこだわらず
ネタとして面白いかどうかを気にすると
色々と新しいことに挑戦するのが
楽しくなってきます
先ほど言ったように僕は現在人力飛行機の
プロのパイロットを目指しています
将来がかかっていて
僕にとって非常に重要な取り組みですが
実は
失敗したとき
プロになれなかった時のことをあまり深刻
に考えていませんというのももし失敗した
としても
世界で初めて人に飛行機のパイロットに
なろうとしたっていうことをおそらく僕
一生こすり続けますめちゃめちゃネタにし
ますそれはそれで美味しいんじゃないか
なってどっかで思ってるんですよね
ただ
世界で初めて人的のパイロットになっ
たっていうのがおそらく一番おいしいんで
今そのために色々やってるっていう感じ
です
僕は
損得とか
成功とか
失敗とか
役に立つかどうかよりも
ネタ作りとして面白いかどうかを
重要視しています
だってよく考えてみてください
僕の青春も全てを捧げて取り組んでいる鳥
人間一体何の役に立つでしょうか
何の役にも立たないんですよそんなものの
ために大学卒業5年も伸ばして冷静に
考えると飛行機を飛ばす遊びにうつつを
抜かしてるただのポンコツなんです
[拍手]
僕は鳥人間コンテストで優勝するために
色々なことを犠牲にしてきましたが
9年間の
取り組みが
結果として表れず引退することだって十分
にあり得ます
鳥人間コンテストにここまで没頭して
没頭してしまったこと自体が一般的には
失敗と呼ぶべきことだったのかもしれませ
ん
けど
ネタ作りとしてみたらどうでしょうか
大学9年生
鳥人間コンテストに3回出場
Mr筑波大学にもなりました
鳥人間のチームを1個作って潰してさらに
もう一個作ったこともあります1年間卒業
に関係ない
体育系の授業を取ったこと
男子校のノリが行き過ぎて高校で謹慎に
なったこと
僕がこれまでやってきたたくさんのやる
場所は人生のネタとなって僕をいろいろな
ところへ連れて行ってくれます
[拍手]
決して皆さんに失敗を糧にネタにするべき
だとは言いません
しかし
役に立たないことばかりやっていますが
僕の人生をかけたネタで誰かが笑顔になっ
てくれたりこんな場所に立っているやつも
案外ポンコツなんだなと知って自信に変え
てもらったり何か面白いことをやってみ
たいなと少しでも思わせることができれば
幸いです
ご清聴ありがとうございました
[拍手]